yeah again I'm playing against my way
from Norway played him so often okay so
we have the advance of the CARICOM
interesting yeah well I need to take
anyway no use to to think too much hmm
this is cute Queen asics I play me maybe
plane see for you okay but it still
looks like should be a reasonable move
this should be four maybe and well
protect the pawn
and yeah complicated to position where
Blackcomb has a slight disadvantage in
space but doesn't look too bad not sure
that this Bishop before business was so
great for me if he castles now I mean
the question is if he castles he
probably threatens to move the night and
then this Bishop is pointing into thin
air and I'm not positive that i want to
take mia maybe something entirely
different yeah do I want to take on g3
this might be very weakening yeah yeah
it is very weakening on the earth file
yeah and I was thinking
yeah I were thinking I can always cast
long but of course I cannot this this
was a very weird idea that I can
consider to Castle long
at five maybe I can go f5 at some point
slight b6 an idea attacking see for now
maybe maybe he goes Queen f3 I can click
through cafe to cover this maybe this
tower to play irritates him enough to UM
to play a defensive move yeah I have
found my doubts about this position
Queen a six and so on maybe this wasn't
a good idea okay but anyway i'm not i'm
not sure what um what white should play
now actually it's not so self-evident
twin f3 ruka fade and i'm still
threatening now maybe you can twin f3
and c5 maybe okay um I must play will
give it right
hmm yeah this is maybe a good good way
to go about that should I take on f3
yeah I can probably do this next smooth
okay and queen age five there's also
bishops III uh huh okay maybe maybe I
can play that it's it's looking really
really risky but should see three
does he have rook takes f7 group text of
seven group takes f7 look f1
yeah maybe
and came on I want to I want to get the
King out of this mess rook f7 I can play
Queen d3 and then taking d 4 + D to so
there should be some counter play and at
least I'm not mated oh this is a simple
way to go about that but I can play of
six
yeah this shouldn't be too bad at least
I hope I bishop 260
okay no not much I can do about that f6
is covered in e6 is always yeah a bit
covered and maybe I'm just thinking I
was always thinking about going I five
but maybe
protect you for
is he threatening something look f6 ya
okay I'm not sure that this is really
such a big deal I mean um I'm just a
jeep on down and whatever thinking about
is this is f5 i prevented that f 59 f 6
would be would be really great let's try
this should be 5 i can take and take g3
should I take
jet
yeah very do the time jet time morning
check
check
only hope is ff-for f3 is contract g7 i
roped g7 yeah probably it was lost
anyway okay press the button yeah I
don't know it felt like it shouldn't be
too bad i mean this night only for but
maybe it's just just dominating too much
the bishop is start pet only five and
then maybe this wasn't wasn't great it
is so bad yeah maybe it is maybe this
it's just the porn okay it's got the H
porn and still maybe the bishop besides
just strong why should a misplay five
maybe of just e 5 rupee for stuff like
that tricky yeah of course I I was in
trouble out of the opening so maybe
maybe this is this wasn't wasn't shot
such such a brilliant idea I have some
awesome something else I mean this this
is tricky yeah very difficult game
thanks for watching